este es el panorama que deja la tormenta
tropical e está a su paso por
centroamérica casas bajo el agua puentes
y carreteras destruidos y árboles
derribados guatemala se ha llevado la
peor parte las autoridades continúan la
búsqueda de más de 100 personas que
siguen desaparecidas unos 44 mil
ciudadanos han sido evacuados pues la
verdad es que nos sacaron como la
tercera noche inmediatamente porque iba
subiendo el río tabo y el río san
francisco una avioneta que transportaba
ayuda humanitaria para los damnificados
chocó al sur de la ciudad de guatemala
minutos después de haber despegado las
causas del siniestro todavía se
desconoce en honduras unas 23 personas
perdieron la vida y las autoridades
adelantan las labores de rescate estados
unidos y guatemala enviaron helicópteros
para ayudar con la misión en la que
participan unos 50.000 rescatistas y
aunque ya se han evacuado más de 16.000
residentes numerosas familias todavía
esperan en sus hogares inundados por el
agua y si están preocupados porque han
pasado blanca el conteo sin nadie no va
a venir bien
y aquí esta tocó tierra en cuba la
mañana de este domingo causando fuertes
lluvias e inundaciones y provocando la
evacuación de al menos 25.000 personas
se espera que siga moviéndose por el sur
de florida causando fuertes vientos e
intensas olas e inundaciones